welcome to my round six recap from Vegas
this was a super long game uh I finished
like 20 minutes ago it's currently 3 46
p.m and the next round starts at five so
I'm gonna try and speed run this recap
uh now the game spoiler alert the game
was
85 moves I think this was my longest
game in terms of moves and duration so
um my opponent played E4 I was playing
FM Austin May who is I believe
um 18 maybe 19 years old uh up and
coming player and I prepared for him
before the game and originally I was
going to play Sicilian but I saw his
rapper tour against E4 E5 and I saw he
plays a lot of Evans Gambit so before
the round I Was preparing basically how
to try and refute that and scan it now I
knew it wasn't a guarantee that he would
go into it but just to show if Bishop C4
Bishop C5 B4 I was prepping this a lot
um so unfortunately we did not enter the
Evan scan that would have been a fun
opening to have but instead he played
the Spanish which is a bit more
mainstream uh probably a better choice
given that
um yeah it's just a more reliable
opening and it's not something I
prepared so much before the game because
I only found like a couple games he's
played this before
so I went for the mainline A6 Bishop A4
I have six castle Bishop E7 and I was
playing uh a marshall move order so if
rookie won Castle C3 I would have the
option of going into the Marshall or
wait no um after rookie one uh B5 First
bishop B3 Castle C3 this position I
would have the option of going for
Marshall or maybe uh more kind of
traditional line
but uh instead of rookie one he played
Pawn to D3 and I'll admit that I was
basically out of any specific prep after
D3
uh yeah it's been a while since I like
studied the Spanish from the lock side
very seriously I was trying to remember
like the nuances and the nepo ding match
because they they went into a lot of
spanishes but um I was pretty much on my
own uh but I knew the idea that D3
defends the pawn so white is threatening
to take and then take on E5 so for that
reason I play Pawn D6 and then C3 and
the next several moves were all pretty
natural it's developing uh Bishop V2
rookie 8 A4 and this was maybe the first
decision that uh I have to make is what
to do with a threat of a takes B5 and
basically there's three options I was
considering between Rook B8 Bishop B7
and B4
and ultimately I chose to play B4 I
thought this is a nice way to try and
change the structure on the queen side
and then he plays A5 and this is a
typical positional idea to fix the pawn
on E6 so I can't play A5 myself also
setting up maybe potential ideas of
Bishop A4 but the game continues Rook B8
Knight D2 Bishop f8 Knight C4 and
basically my plan here was to get a
setup with G6 Bishop G7 but the bishop
on D7 and then later go for this Knight
H5 and F5 idea and we're gonna see the
next several moves play out exactly
according to my plan I start with Bishop
D7
uh Bishop D2 G6 H3 Bishop G7
and it just seemed like white wasn't
really doing much of anything productive
like the bishop came to A4 but I was
just carrying through with um all the
moves I wanted to play after Bishop G5
this did perhaps misplace my queen but I
thought the queen is useful on C8
creating the battery and there's also
ideas of maybe Queen B7 to exert more
pressure on the queen side so Queen D2
is played and in this position I took a
long think because I was trying to
figure out the best approach to make
progress on the king side and this is
where I paused to have some water
important to stay hydrated
so after a long think I decided to play
at six even though Ben Feingold says
never play F6 and the idea is to chase
the bishop back to E3 where it's
arguably a little bit misplaced like
even though it's centralized it takes
away the Square from the knights and
then I play F5 threatening to trap the
bishop with F4
so I was feeling uh like momentum was in
my favor but it's still a really complex
position and
um I will say I haven't checked this
with engine so I really don't know
what the true evaluation is I don't know
where the mistakes or blunders were made
if any but um the position is definitely
getting exciting so my opponent took uh
very quickly actually which surprised me
because after it takes
I have the option of of course taking
back but when I played F5 I was
initially calculating that I can play D5
here
and I spent a long time trying to decide
between Pawn takes pawn and D5 and this
would essentially trap the knights but
it's not so simple and my opponent was
telling me after the game that he was
considering
um either FTX G6 which I didn't even see
as an option but also G4 and then uh it
just gets really messy after it takes
takes I spent a long time trying to
calculate this position and just so much
Pawn tension on both sides of the board
and ultimately I decided to not go for
D5 but just to recapture
and this keeps a little bit more control
because now I'm still threatening to
play F4 and there's still ideas of D5 so
white does have to be very careful
and he went for a very concrete line
which is maybe the only playable line is
Bishop H6
I play F4 cutting off the relationship
between the queen and Bishop
and after this G7 King G7 he plays Pawn
to D4
and this is where
the the whole position just kind of
explodes because uh White's trying to
just
destroy my amazing Pawn chain and the
following line is relatively forcing
like it's very concrete and I was just
kind of going with the flow the next few
moves I played calling E4 he plays Pawn
D5 counter-attacking my knight
I take on F3 he takes on C6 and then
um in this position originally I was
gonna play Bishop F5 but then I realized
I can take on H3
and the point is Queen G4 is a massive
threat so white has to be like really
really careful here and I thought maybe
I'm on the verge of winning uh because
if he takes on E8 I think I can just go
right in with Queen G4
yeah this looks very strong I mean
there's rookie seven check and then
maybe G3 but uh it seemed way more fun
for black
uh but this didn't happen because after
I took on H3 he found a move to
essentially consolidate a nice
centralizing move Queen D5 uh hitting
the knights and hitting the pawn and I
have nothing better than to go for Queen
G4 uh of course threatening made in one
and then after he takes them at three we
trade queens and just over lost a few
moves the position has transformed
drastically like it went from a very
sharp double-edged middle game position
with tons of tension to now we've
basically liquidated into some kind of
end game with a very weird Pawn
structure uh just Pawn scattered
everywhere White's King is a little bit
weak and I was feeling pretty good here
now I took a bit of time because
um originally I wanted to play the move
Bishop E6 and stop The Rook trade and
then eventually like King F6 and get the
Rook to the G file but then they
realized if I play Bishop E6 there's 19
6d6 and I think this is big trouble for
black because after takes or C7 and then
my Rook actually both Rooks and my
Bishop are all being attacked in various
ways
um so I didn't want to blunder into this
so instead of Bishop E6 I played rookie
6 which uh doesn't allow this tactic and
it aims to lift the rook and essentially
provokes a trade after takes takes I got
Tempo on the Knight he plays Knight D2
and in this position
my opponent told me after the game that
I had a different option than what I
played uh the move I played was an F6
but he was saying that I can I think
move the king and go for Rook G8
which
maybe was a an interesting alternative
again I haven't had much time to analyze
but I played Knight of six with
just idea that the Knight should really
return to the center because it wasn't
doing too much on the edge
um and I thought that maybe eventually
it can maneuver and attack the pawn or
just pressure the queen side but then he
plays C4 ah my opponent actually told me
that uh I should take first to maybe
prevent like from playing C4 which uh
maybe I should have more seriously
considered but um I did give white the
chance to play C4 and he played it and I
thought it's still fine because now the
pawn can be a Target but very soon we're
gonna see how this Pawn becomes useful
for white so after King F7 King H2
Bushcraft five some improving moves the
game proceeds to get really sharp I play
Bishop D3 trying to go after this Pawn
but also setting up Bishop to E2 and
after C5 takes takes I play Bishop E2
and again we're in some very like tricky
kind of tactical line where the F3 Pawn
is hanging and it's not so easy for
white to defend because King G2 runs
into Rook G8 but white is able to take a
counter play after what happened Bishop
B3 check team G6 and then Rook G1 Jack
and I think I maybe underestimated the
danger in this line because I had
calculated the fact that my king will
come to H6 and that F Pawn is still
attacked and if I can take the F Pawn
then there's ideas of Rook B5 uh to
swing over to H5
but when he played this next move
I realized that it's very very scary for
black and I actually completely missed
the fact that he has the uh the next
move
um which I think is the strongest move
in the position so if you want to try
and find white snacks move uh feel free
to pause the video and the move he
played is Knight to D7 and this was just
a blind spot for me I didn't realize
that uh this is like a very forcing
option in the position and I can't just
defend my knight because the Knight also
controls f8
uh so basically we're in a situation
or I'm in the situation where I have to
trade and now white has a very dangerous
past Pawn on D7 and I have to be very
careful of ideas of Rook 2 G8 and then
just eventually queening for white
now in this position uh I played the
move Rook d8
but for a moment I thought I had a
brilliant line which unfortunately
doesn't work I really wanted to play the
move Bishop takes F3 with idea that
after Rook G8 I would have the move Rook
to B5 and this line almost Works black
is threatening made in two so like
Queens check and mates on each one
uh the reason why I didn't go for this
is because of Bishop E6
if not for Bishop E6 I think maybe it's
it's okay for black
um but Bishop E6 aims to play Bishop H3
and now I can't stop the pawn so I want
to check this with the engine as Bishop
E6
oh there's multiple winning moves for
lights Bishop E6 Bishop F7 even King G1
is winning
ah King G1 Rook H5 and then King F1
Okay so yeah it was just a fantasy that
this line could work for black
so I played the move Rook d8 to blockade
the pawn
he plays Bishop E6 and now the game just
revolves around this G7 Pawn I really
want to try and win it but he has a very
strong move here Rook C1 and if I take
the pawn he's not gonna uh trade he's
gonna just pin my bishop and I uh I
would be losing material here so the
Pawn's not capturable and now my C7 Pawn
is hanging so my only move is to play
Pawn C6 and then he moves back to G1 and
so now he's threatening Rook Gates
because my Bishop no longer hits D7 so I
played Pawn C5 unleashing the bishop and
then he moves back to C1 and now my C
Pawn is a Target and I still can't take
on D7 with the bishop so I play C4 I'm
still kind of just going with the flow
like a lot of my moves are only moves
here but then the position liquidates
because he takes on C4 I take on D7 he
takes on B5 I take and after Rook C6
check I I'm beginning to realize that
this end game is very very difficult to
hold because white has a more active
rook and the more dangerous cast Pawn on
top of that my pawns are all potentially
weak
um now White's pawns are maybe
potentially weak as well but uh White
has initiative here so that does not
bode well in Black's favor but I tried
to fight King G5 Rook C5 and then King
H4 trying to activate the king
uh he plays Rook F5 which I think is a
very accurate move not taking on B5 if
he takes on B5 I would win back the pawn
and I really just want to trade as many
pawns as possible to try and have
drawing chances
but after Rook F5 uh he wants to take on
F4 with check so I play Rook A7 trying
to get rid of this Pawn but then he
takes on B5 so defending and going after
my B4 pawn and at this point I'm
realizing I'm in like serious serious
trouble and um yeah with accurate play
White should be able to win but I still
have a few tricks up my sleeve I played
the move
on H5
and at this point I am dreaming of a
scenario where let's say white plays B3
then I can take on A5 and say oh no my
rook and if takes it would be stalemate
so H5 is potentially setting up some
still Matrix but I think he was very
aware of that he takes on B4 after I
take on A5 he takes on F4
situation where it's three pawns against
one but it still takes technique for
white
I play Team G5 he plays Rook B4
I play Rook A1
he plays King G2 Rook B1 B3 King F5 Rook
B5 check King F4
and again I'm dreaming of like
stalemating ideas like if I don't have
this Pawn here actually if I take the
pawn and Rook off the board when he's
not looking then it would be still neat
um who did that in in New York there's
some viral video
I think it was Dina Valencia who was
like playing the street Hustler and just
removed all her pieces from the board
until it was still amazed I'm coming to
see you girl no yeah no yeah
you ain't got nothing right there
what's going on now girl let's see I
finally beat you from Russia because you
wasn't paying attention
stalemate sir
but yeah that would not fly in a v-day
classical tournament
so um anyway my opponent played B4 I
played H4 Rook H5 and this is a very
accurate move because now if I take the
pawn
fan takes and I lose my rook and there's
no stale Matrix so after Rook H5 I play
H3 but the problem here is after Rook H3
I'm still not able to take the b-pawn
and now it's three pawns against no
Pawns
um and My Hope was beginning to fade and
I think I'll just zoom through the next
few moves there's next many moves
because we'll see whites very accurate
technique
um he was gradually making progress on
the king side
and yeah my only hope was that he would
play a move like B6 and then in the
event of this move I would
play this let's say check here and now
it's an awkward situation for white
because if he waits then I have this
move and this would be a draw actually
because I get rid of the b-pawn and
takes it's a nice stalemate with a king
on F5
um the problem was that he never even
gave me this opportunity to set up the
trick uh he started with F5 and white
still gradually makes progress
only so much my rooking team can do and
then eventually he
just gives me the F5 pawn and then gives
me the F4 Pawn but all white needs is
one strong pass Pawn to win the game and
this is actually an example of the
Lucina position when
um it's rook in one versus rook and the
defending side is uh is basically cut
off
my King has no way to get to the same
files upon so this is a theoretically
winning end game and my opponent had um
Flawless technique yeah it was not too
difficult to win because my king is so
far away and all white needed to do was
ensure the king can come to the C file
and there's no way to stop the pawn from
queening so it was a very tough game uh
85 moves ended up losing
um what was a very long fight I don't
know exactly where I went wrong in this
game
um maybe like maybe going all the way
back I should not have allowed this
Ponzi 4 move but I don't know and I
don't really have much time to analyze
because the next round starts in 54
minutes so I do appreciate if you made
it this far I really hope for those
watching you learned a thing or two in
some sense these these uh Recaps are
therapeutic for me it's it allows me to
just reflect on what just happened and
try and uh move on to the next game
so uh thanks again for watching I'll be
back soon uh stay tuned for more Recaps
on YouTube and another live stream on
Twitch except probably by the time I
will post this video the tournament will
be over but just follow on Twitch and
YouTube anyway and I'll see you guys
soon